JACK STERN ADDED SELDEN ISN'T
EVEN HIDING THE ANTI-SEMITISM
ANYMORE.
CONGRESSMAN, I BELIEVE YOU ARE
RUNNING TO BE THE FIRST JEWISH
GOVERNOR IN NEW YORK HISTORY, I
THAT RIGHT?
TO KEEP THE FIRST JEWISH
REPUBLICAN.
IT IS HARD TO POINT OUT THAT HE
IS SOMEBODY THAT HAS LONG RECOR
OF STRENGTHENING RELATIONSHIPS
WITH THE JEWISH COMMUNITY
STRENGTHENING THE U.S. AND FOR
MYSELF WHEN I FIRST GOT TO
CONGRESS I WAS THE ONLY JEWISH
REPUBLICAN I AM CURRENTLY ONE O
TO AND I'VE BEEN ACTIVE IN THES
EFFORTS WILL DOING THE
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE JEWISH
COMMUNITY, SO IT IS REALLY
IGNORANT TO TRY TO ATTACK RON
AND I, BUT THEY ARE GETTING
DESPERATE.
>> IT'S LAUGHABLE ON ITS FACE.
THE GOVERNOR'S RESPONSE
MEANWHILE TO THOSE SURGING CRIM
IN NEW YORK, WATCH THIS.
>> THESE ARE MASTER MANIPULATORS
, THEY HAVE THIS
CONSPIRACY GOING ALL ACROSS
AMERICA TO CONVINCE PEOPLE IN
DEMOCRATIC STATES ARE NOT AS
SAFE OR THEY'RE NOT ONLY
ELECTION DENIERS, THEY ARE
DAVITT DENIERS.
>> CONGRESSMAN, ARE YOU A DATA
DENIER?
>> IT WAS JUST A FEW WEEKS AGO
HAD A DRIVE-BY GANG-RELATED
SHOOTING ON MY FRONT YARD WHILE
MY 16 -YEAR-OLD DAUGHTERS WE'RE
SITTING AT THE KITCHEN TABLE
DOING HOMEWORK ON A QUIET SUNDA
AFTERNOON.
THERE WERE PEOPLE LAYING ON THE
GROUND SHOT JUST 10 FEET FROM
WHERE THEY ARE.
WE HAD A RIKERS ISLAND
CORRECTION OFFICER IN THE LAST
FEW HOURS GOT STABBED 15 TIMES
AND IS NOW IN THE HOSPITAL IN
QUEENS AND HOPEFULLY IS ABLE TO
HAVE A FULL RECOVERY.
THAT'S WHERE OUR THOUGHTS AND
PRAYERS ARE IN NEW YORK.
WE ARE SEEING THE VIDEOS OF THE
PEOPLE ARE GETTING DAY AFTER DA
THROWN ONTO THE TRACKS IN SOME
CASES ACTUALLY KILLED BY CARS
THAT ARE COMING, BUT WE HAVE
STORIES COMING FROM AROUND THE
STATE WHERE FOR EXAMPLE A LONG
ISLAND DAD IS VISITING HIS KID
FOR PARENTS WEEKEND AND IS
GRABBING A CUP OF COFFEE
CHECKING OUT OF THE HOTEL AND
ENDS UP GETTING SHOT.
WE CAN RECAP THE STORIES THE
HIGH-PROFILE STORIES FROM THE
LAST THREE WEEKS, AND YOU WOULD
THINK WE ARE RECAPPING A LIST
FROM THE LAST THREE YEARS.
KATHY WANTS TO CALL US
CONSPIRACY THEORISTS FOR STATIN
RAW FAXBACK TO NVIDIA NVIDIA
WITH ACTUAL VICTIMS?
THIS IS WHY SHE IS SO OUT OF
TOUCH AT LAST WEEK'S DEBATE SHE
SAID SHE DOESN'T UNDERSTAND
WHITE WALKING UP CRIMINALS IS S
IMPORTANT TO ME WHEN SHE SAYS
THAT IT'S A MESSAGE TO NEW
YORKERS THAT SHE DOESN'T CARE O
UNDERSTAND WHY THIS IS SO
IMPORTANT TO EVERYONE.
ITS ONE OF THE MAIN REASON SHE